Okay, I'm going to go through a few more
calls. So, let me call man. Let's see.
Take few more callers and I got to go.
>> [music]
>> Sergonis and Aziza, Sergon.
What happened, dude?
Hello, how's it going? I don't know. It
depends if you're a friend or foe and
you want to blaspheme. How's it going? I
don't know. I I
I can't hear you.
Uh
I'm a Christian. You sure? With that
kind of name you got? EUL Ellie Hubel?
EUL.
And what's Ellie Hubel? Hubel means the
bell.
>> Uh yeah.
No, that's my last name. I'm I'm
Ethiopian. Okay, praise the Lord, bro.
Sorry about that, man. If you're
Ethiopian, you're kosher. You're
Trinitarian. You worship the Lord Jesus
Christ as the God man, right?
Uh yes, sir. What are you Eritrean? Is
that it?
Uh no, we're um we're different.
[snorts] Okay, so I'm sorry. I confuse
everyone. But what church? What's your
church affiliation? Are you Ethiopian
Orthodox? Yeah.
Yeah, I'm Orthodox at the moment. Yes.
And you have 81 books in your Bible,
right?
Um yep. Okay. I I've I've just recently
gotten to Christianity, so I don't
really know. Not too much. So, you just
got Even though you come from the
Orthodox background, you just got on
fire for Jesus. What's your question, my
brother?
All right. So, um I have a question
about um icons. Oh, yes.
And like kneeling before icons.
>> Yes.
Yes. I was hoping like asking if it's
like idolatry or something, you know.
>> question. Now, I have an article on it
and I've done sessions on it. I'm going
to give you all that material.
If you had asked me this question
had you asked me this question maybe
over 10 years ago, I would have said
it's idolatry
because of my very what we call myopic
limited view and reading of scripture
because of the influence of Protestant
theology. Now,
when I say that, brother, I'm not saying
Protestant theology is wrong.
But remember, any attempt by humans to
systematize
biblical teaching is going to be
with error. No one
can systematize the teaching of the
Bible perfectly, flawlessly unless
they're inspired by the Holy Spirit to
do so, right?
Yes. So, you're going to find a lot of
things in Protestant theology that's
solid, biblical, and a lot that's not.
And even in Protestant theology, you're
going to find a lack of uniformity. They
agree on a lot of things, but disagree
on a lot of things. So,
for example, if I'm correct and the
people can correct me here.
If you go to a Lutheran church, they
have icons.
I mean, in other words, on their on the
mirrors, on their windows, they have
images. Am I correct, guys? From what I
recall,
in a Lutheran church, I think I've seen
images, what we call icons, on their
windows.
All over. Now, again, if I'm wrong, Lord
forgive me, but I think I'm right cuz I
remember seeing it. So, what's my point?
Depending on what tradition you ask,
they're going to tell you it is
idolatry. But now, after further
reflection and meditation on the word of
God and church history, I've come to see
it's not idolatry because God himself in
the Bible fashioned, commissioned
icons to be fashioned that people were
to look to for spiritual benefit. I'll
give you one example. Do you have a
Bible on you? What's up, Anika, my
sister? God bless you, sister. Good to
see you.
Are you ready?
>> Yes, I do. Okay, open up your Bible to
Exodus 25:18-22.
All right.
Good question, my brother.
Exactly, icons are not idolatry.
If they're properly used. Now, you have
some Christians who are ignoramuses that
misuse icons, but in a mis- a misuse and
abuse of something doesn't mean that it
invalidates that practice and
observance.
So, now in Exodus 25:18-22.
Read that.
>> Exodus 25 Yep, 18 to 22.
All right.
Okay.
And thou shalt make two cherubims of
gold of beaten work shalt thou make them
in the two ends of the mercy seat. And
make one cherubim on the one end and the
other cherubim on the other end. Even
even of the mercy seat shall ye make the
cherubim cherubims on on the two ends
thereof.
You want all the way to 22. Don't stop.
All the way to 22. You ready? All right.
And the cherubims shall stretch forth
their wings on high covering the mercy
seat with their wings. And their face
shall look onto one onto another. Toward
the mercy seat shall the faces of the
cherubims be. And thou shalt put the
mercy seat above upon the ark. And in
the ark thou shalt put the testimony
that I shall give thee. And there I will
meet with thee and I will commune with
thee from above the mercy seat, from
between the two cherubims which are upon
the ark of the testimony of all things
which I will give thee in commandment
unto the children of Israel. So, now God
himself fashioned
the image of cherubim and the mercy seat
representing God's throne in heaven.
He's the one who had it fashioned,
right?
Uh yes. And he says that's where I'm
going to meet you. I'm going to appear
visibly there. And let me just correct
He is risen.
He is risen. No, you don't worship what
the icon represents unless it's an icon
of God.
You honor what the icon represents. If
it's an icon of an apostle, prophet, a
saint of the Lord Jesus Christ used
mightily by God or an angel, but you
don't worship them. So, be careful,
He is risen because you have people here
and I say this cuz I love you, brother.
There are people here who are looking at
every word we say to use it against us
to condemn us and slander us in our
freedom in Christ. I know cuz I was
there.
So, be careful what you say, please.
Be careful what you say. So, my brother,
did you just read God
commanding Moses to fashion an icon of
spiritual beings in heaven that stand
before his throne, the cherubim?
Uh yeah. Okay. Now, let me show you how
they venerated the ark of the covenant.
Go to Joshua 7:6 and I'm going to give
you the article. Guys, here's my article
on icons. And thank our brother
Protestant, he created a playlist on all
my series on icons and communion of
saints. It's okay, He is risen. I know
you meant well, brother, but I'm just
doing that to help you so they don't use
your words against you cuz I know what
you mean. Others don't. Now,
here's the here's the link to the
article, folks, for you guys, the
benefit of you guys to read it. Now,
I'll send it to you in the in the
comment section here, but go to Joshua
7:6.
All right, I'm there. Do I read it? Yes.
Then Joshua tore his clothes and fell
face down to the ground before the ark
of the Lord, remaining there till
evening. The elder The elders of Israel
did the same and sprinkle sprinkled dust
on their heads.
>> So, they bowed down
before the ark?
Yeah. All the way till evening?
Yes. And God didn't condemn them for
that?
No, he didn't. Okay. Now, let me show
you the power of this icon of the ark of
the covenant. That believe it or not,
and I want everyone to hear this. You
got to understand how icons, idols work.
You guys may not know this or you may
not realize the significance of this.
You can ask anyone who's dabbled into
exorcism
and they'll tell you that the spirit
realm the spirit realm will attach
themselves to physical objects and work
through those physical objects.
So, in the ancient world, it was
believed that an icon wasn't merely
simply some image, but the icon would
also have the presence of that being
attached to it. This is why Paul says,
when you sacrifice idols, it's not the
idol that's anything. It's the demons
that are attached to the idols that
you're sacrificing to and when you do,
you enter into communion with them.
You guys know that? First Corinthians
10:19-22,
specifically verse 20.
Brother, if you can, go to the First
Corinthians 10. Check Go to First
Corinthians 10. Read 19 to 22. It's
really 19 to 20, but 20 specifically.
Watch.
Watch what it says. If you can go there.
Okay.
Um do I mean then that food sacrificed
to an idol is anything or that an idol
is anything? No, but the sacrifices of
pagans are offered to demons, not to
God. So, when you sacrifice, brother,
to an idol of a god or a goddess, you're
actually sacrificing to that demon that
has deceived those people to thinking
that's a god or goddess. In other words,
if you believe the Bible, Zeus is real
in that Zeus is a demon, an evil spirit
appearing as a god. So, it's not that
Zeus doesn't exist. The being that
appears as Zeus exists, but he's not
really Zeus. He's a demon appearing as a
god to mislead you to worship him.
Everyone got that?
Everyone understand that point?
Yeah, like Allah. Thank you. Baal.
Right? Now, so if you got that, now let
me show you the power of holy images.
The power of holy icons. An icon of a
holy saint of Jesus Christ or of the
Godhead or an angelic being working for
the Lord. That too can bring about a
spiritual power and a force and a
blessing from God. How do I know? Go to
1 Samuel chapter 4 verse 4.
Right? Right.
Right.
Yeah. Do I just read it? Yes, go ahead.
So
So the people sent men to Shiloh, and
they brought back the ark of the
covenant of the Lord Almighty, who was
enthroned between the cherubim. And
Eli's two sons,
Hophni and Phinehas Yes. were there with
the ark of the were there with the ark
of the covenant of God.
>> Okay, did you hear what you read? That
physical ark of the covenant, we're told
is where God dwells.
Yeah. Yes. You see it?
Yeah. So a physical icon and God's
presence is attached to it?
Yeah, yes. Okay, now. So and they
brought like the ark of the covenant of
the Lord Almighty. Now go to 1 Samuel
chapter 5 verses 3 to 4.
1 Samuel chapter 5 verses 3 to 4.
Uh Alicia, it'd be considered using a
physical
object, an item, that God created
through which he will bestow spiritual
blessings. Now in 1 Samuel chapter 5
verses 3 and 4.
When the people of Ashdod rose early the
next day, there was there was Dagon fell
on fallen on his face on the ground
before the ark of the Lord.
>> Okay, did you read that, brother? Before
you read.
Uh the idol of the false god Dagon,
Dagon of the Philistines. They found the
idol fallen before the ark of the
covenant, cuz the Philistines brought
the ark of the covenant into the temple
of their false god Dagon. When they put
the ark there, they came and saw the
idol fell before the ark of the
covenant.
Did you guys catch that? Are you
catching that, brother? You see the
power of the icon of the ark of God's
throne?
In contrast to the icon of the false god
Dagon?
They took the ark, put it in the temple
of Dagon, the false god. They come and
there the statue of their god prostrate
before the true god, the icon of God's
throne.
Right?
Yeah. Now keep reading, though.
Keep reading.
But the following morning when they
rose, there was Dagon fallen on his face
on the ground before the ark of the
Lord. His head and hands had been broken
off and were lying on the thresh-
threshold. Only his body remained. Wow.
Now the next day, they saw the statue of
Dagon not only fallen before the ark,
but in pieces, head and hands torn off.
But no human being did it.
Who do you think came in
and destroyed the idol of Dagon and
forced it to be prostrate before the ark
of God? God almighty.
So why is God honoring the icon of his
throne and dishonoring the icon of a
false god? Because God is not against
icons. He's against He's against idols,
icons of false gods and goddesses that
you worship and look to look to besides
the true god.
Yeah. You see that?
>> Yes, cuz I um yeah, I used to watch like
the videos of um David Lynn he would
he would kind of condemn um iconography
and that kind of worried
>> Can I tell you something, brother?
Listen to me, I mentioned this again.
Be Stay away from David Lynn. He's not a
Bible scholar. He's a biblical
ignoramus.
People made him a celebrity cuz
supposedly he got arrested because he
spoke out against homosexuality. So
what? You have a lot of cultists that
get arrested for their false beliefs.
But I'm going to say it again. You hear
what this man just said? He heard David
Lynn speak out against iconography as if
David Lynn is a Bible authority. I have
spoken out against them and condemned
them publicly because David Lynn
provided a platform for an
anti-Trinitarian, a modalist, who denies
the Trinity and worships a false god,
who he claims to be the god of the
Bible, and claims to receive revelation
from God as a prophet named Marcus
Rogers. When I confronted him about that
man, instead of publicly condemning
Marcus Rogers, he made excuses to defend
him and justify him working with Marcus
Rogers. David Lynn is not a person to
learn your faith from. Ignore him, stay
away from him.
And that's ironic, isn't it? He'll
attack the Catholic Church, who are
die-hard Trinitarians, who love the
triune God, attack the Orthodox Church,
who love and worship the triune God, but
with Marcus Rogers, who used to debate
Trinitarians and try to prove
Trinitarianism wrong, who now says God
told him, "Don't debate Trinitarians,
work with them." So now he wants them to
enter Trinitarian churches to deceive
them with his lies,
him he's okay with.
Yeah, that's kind of
That's [snorts] That's not good.